[Music]
hello and welcome to sidetrek your
sci-fi tv and movie channel
every video just makes my life so much
easier to say at the start instead of
just going hello
and i am joined with by matt today the
chap that runs our discord thank god
because i don't know how that works
at all not even a bit um
matt before we get started mate you want
to tell them about your channel because
you're not just with us for fun
you um you have your own channel as well
tell us what sort of things you do and
where we can find you while i just turn
a plug on that i forgot to turn up so my
channel is my name it's matt dean um
although i don't know if the youtube
algorithm actually knows my name yet so
if you just type in youtube.com
him2
you can find me i do uh it's a it's a
long story it's world username um i do
doctor who content primarily at the
moment it's meant to be a sci-fi channel
but
without doctor who news we've had
recently i've just become the doctor who
guy so if you like doctor who you like
news and leaks and spoilers and theories
and things like that then come come and
say hello
yeah
i don't like doctor who
they don't i haven't liked dog food talk
to you
i love doctor who but i'm not something
smart stuff left
andrew how are you doing shelly how you
doing we've got a couple of members in
which is always great
today any member comments that come up
and any super chats that we see i will
be reading that we will discuss so if
you want if you've got something burning
you need to tell us
send us a does a super chat because
every penny counts helps me create more
content blah blah blah um
just small amounts don't do like i saw
somebody send me some god bless him i
love you very much because i'm just like
a 15 quid super chat and i felt so bad
i quit it was fine
anyway and elise and nicholas are with
us as well so let's get into it we're
going to talk about stargate today we're
going to talk about anything we want to
talk about but
um i will also if everybody wants we can
have a bit of a um rundown of how we've
got to where we're at at the moment
where we are at
a bit of a bit of a i'll tell you i'll
do a quick recap then i've got a couple
of things i wanted to talk about but
we've already served my map
so
this all started three years ago now
nearly 2019 with giant freaking robot
sending out a story
saying that there was two series of
stargate that we're going to get
released or going to get green lit by
mgm and the first one being a live
action one um written by brad wright and
um an animated series which everybody
was very excited about the animated
series
um because animated series and stargate
that went well first time
so was it was it what was it called
start getting infinity so i never
actually watched it
yeah i never watched either
um i think i saw one or two episodes
before i saw bits but um so joey
freaking robot put that story out i
actually did a video based on that
nonsense because i didn't realize giant
freaking robot was a bunch of crap
um
and
um their book and soul said what's that
in dollars uh us dollars and pounds are
about the same at the moment
and i think dollars are a little bit
more expensive well they're not much
they're about the same
um so
um
i actually did a video based on that and
nine months ago that got a hundred
thousand views
mentally it's the one video i've done
that was actually wrong
and it's got the most views
make no sense
and
but
i then got a message from somebody that
works for a company close to mgm that
basically said that story is not true um
technically but it was true
about 12 months ago that was the plan
under the executive in charge of
scripted material
um at that point so this would have been
2019.
he had this brilliant idea that mgm
should do an animated series they used
to actually at the time
have
um an mgm animated um company but that
went defunct so i think they were
thinking they would use that and
whatever
then steve wright took over in 2020
is the new scripted george batterini
thank you very much sir every little
helps
uh dinos hot topics hello
i was looking forward to this game
matt what game
there was a
game in production target worlds it was
an mmo
oh yeah yeah
now we've got stargate timekeepers and
it does look like the most boring game
that's ever been made but we could talk
about a bit
i've not seen too much about it to be
honest it just looks really boring you
i'm just like a blip and then you walk
over here and you know like it shows you
a thing where you can see the um there's
jaffas and you can see where they're
looking so you can sneak behind him and
stuff i'm hoping it's like a mobile
phone game because if it's sounds like
an rts game it is an rts game
yeah um it might be all right i quite
like rts games
so anyway um
so brad wright wrote a script
for um stargate to come back this is the
script that he's talked about quite a
lot that was supposed to sound like a
bit like stargate academy there was
going to be a lot of new people involved
uh andrew with all the changes lately
about amazon is wrong and emerick's
still in the mix we could talk about
that can you remind me about that
because it's about contracts and stuff
so we can talk about that in a bit
um
so
um
they did
they did the script it was all planned
out they were going to go for it and
then covered it and everything got put
on pause
during the coveted pandemic then amazon
bought mgm
very quickly amazon kept going on and on
apparently they were really excited
about stargate and they wanted they kept
calling it the sleeping giant of sci-fi
and they were really pushing to bring it
back but they weren't massively excited
about brad wright's vision for the pilot
so they did sort of like put a bit of
pressure on him to rewrite the script
this is something i said a year ago and
then recently we found out that at the
time
he did rewrite the script and that's
actually he's confirmed that to me
himself that he rewrote the script about
12 months ago
and about the time amazon initially
bought mgm while we're waiting for it to
go to the ftc and everything
so
the rumors have continued that amazon
aren't massively excited about brad
wright's vision for this and they think
it could be could think bigger they want
to do tv series movies and all sorts
um
over the time there's been discussions
that michael shanks would come back and
direct as well as appeared potentially
on camera and that amanda tapping would
come back but she would only have maybe
a small part and she would actually come
back as executive producer or even god
forbid apparently there have been
conversations that would she like to
come back as the showrunner if brad
wright didn't but we'll come back to
that
then early this year we had two scripts
so there were two scripts running around
one is a complete mystery but randomly i
know exactly how it started because one
of the people i talked to saw it
um and a second script that is brad
writes
um
never knew where this first group came
from but early this year amazon decided
to drop it
and they decided they're going with
brad's um so mgm sorry decided to drop
it no going with brad's and they were
preparing a big presentation for amazon
executives
for april
then obviously just before april the
sale actually went through ftc so amazon
took control they had these big meetings
in april and then everything hit the fan
completely and amazon announced
basically to mgm you know all that stuff
we were telling you about how we were
going to be really honest
um and let you do your own thing well we
lied and you're not gonna be allowed to
do your own thing and in fact we're
probably gonna dismantle mgm as a
company
and just use the name the two head
executives in charge of mgm left or were
pushed
um and that is basically where where
we're at at the moment in a big
no man's land i've not really been
hunted and going from two or three
months ago being absolutely certain brad
wright or looking like he's absolutely
certain brad wright's project was going
to get made even gateworld and all these
other people that haven't got any goods
to say anything that's not you know if
it's if it's not nailed on they don't
say it
um
even they were saying that it's almost
certainly going to happen
um
and now it looks we're waiting on amazon
it sounds like amazon still want to do
this but they're going to do it it won't
be done at mgm or through mgm studios it
looks like it might be done through
amazon studios so which puts us into a
bit of a known landslide
that's everything
that's that's it that's where we're at
at the moment
so any any parts that you wanted to jump
on or that you're not sure about or
no i i do want to talk about the
potential of
you said either shanks or tapping
directing
it it looks like i've obviously michael
shanks and amanda tapping have both been
quite successful in directing since and
i mean they both direct episodes back in
the day
um
michael shank i mean brad wright has
quite openly talked about that he would
love michael shanks and the manchester
to both come back and potentially be
behind the camera but i mean really
amanda tapping's career ever since
or the series she left stargate for
gonna forget the name of it now
oh i want to say monastery but it wasn't
monastery but it was something serious
like that um
she she executive produced that she's
done a load of directions she's directed
all sorts of tv series the way over the
years so that's really where her passion
lies she's won a few awards
she's now executive producing a tv
series called salem's lot or something
like that salem something um
for sale thank you for saying sorry yeah
um
[Music]
and i think if they if she came back to
the show she would at very least want to
come back as an executive producer
they're not going to get her back just
as an actress because i think she would
consider that a step back in her career
what what do you think about this
potential idea though of her if if for
some reason if they didn't go with brad
and we could talk about the
ups and downs of of maybe take a breath
or not
if they didn't go with brad how would
you feel about maybe like amanda tapping
coming back as showrunner she's never
done it before she's never been a
showrunner
yeah she's never been a showrunner she
has directed
uh she directed one episode of sg-1
didn't she it was resurrection i think
she directed a couple but yeah but she
definitely directed resurrection
she's directed all sorts since
yeah i'm just looking at her was it imdb
just to see what i i would have seen
um she's directed things like travelers
which is a fantastic show i've never
seen from brad wright she'd write nine
episodes of that she's uh directed an
episode of the flash batwoman as you
said fort salem
supernatural
i think she directed several episodes of
supernatural didn't she i think yeah for
four episodes apparently she was
credited with maybe she did more but she
just wasn't credited i'm not sure
um
yeah if
she came and she was
i don't know how i feel if she was show
runner but i definitely would like to
see her in some sort of
in the directing chair or giving some
direction you know towards how the show
is gonna go because she's been
well she's been
on the other side of the camera so she
knows
what stargate is meant to be
and now she's obviously gone to the
other other side of the camera to direct
and she knows how that that works and i
think i think she's got
she would bring a lot to the table
when i think she is ambitious though
that's where i i'm thinking that that it
might be a possibility
because i mean she left stargate to do
sanctuary
where she was a producer or executive
producer
um it was really her show
she did you know she was really the
driving force behind it
um
you know that only lasted three seasons
i think off top of my head i only
watched the first season it wasn't very
good to be honest
um
and you know now she's with for salem
where again i think she's executive
producer i think she was she produced
the first one seat for the second season
though she's executive producer
um
so yeah she says she's a producer for
that on here
yeah it's a producer i think she's
executive producer for the third season
they're about to do
and because one of the producers left
executive producers left
um so i mean she is ambitious and she
would like to i think it's if she comes
back she's definitely going to get a
producer or an executive producer or i
don't think they'll get a back else i
don't think she'd she'd do it sort of
thing but um
but but yeah i mean think i think as a
show runner
i mean
somebody said to me that goes at the
time well you've got to be a writer to
be a showrunner you know you've got to
have the vision of the thing and i said
well no that's nonsense because kevin
feige isn't a writer
um as far as i know he's never written
anything um but he's probably the most
important show runner of the last 20
years because he's basically
masterminded marvel
um
if
yeah and if you're basically showing us
nowadays or managers
you know they they're they're keeping
everything together um i don't know
about kurtzman i don't really know much
about kurtzman i don't know much about
him before star trek but when he's was
he ever a writer i don't really know
um don't care either to us but um but
again he's a manager he's not he's not
um a writer um as far as i know um you
can google it or on
um so i mean
i don't know um
i don't see any reason why she couldn't
i i think she's got the experience she
knows
how to run series she's never gone i
mean it would be a massive project to be
your first project they wouldn't let's
be honest
yeah
but this whole conversation is based
around the idea that it would only be if
brad wright didn't come back
so let's let's talk about the elephants
in the room uh a little bit stargate
universe where do you stand us target
universe you're a lover or a not so sure
i loved it the first so
when it first aired
it was very clearly different it was
definitely
different to sg1 and atlantis but i was
on board
the first season
wasn't great
it wasn't awful like i don't think it
was terrible i don't think it deserves
as much hate as it gets that start
second season
yeah
second season was fantastic
it's just a shame
um how it played out with the you know
mgm's finances and
that thing you said with last week with
the uh the sets
the them whatever the money anyway it's
just a shame they couldn't do season
three because i think
even if they only did three seasons that
third season would have
either
reignited the spark for stargate
yeah and then led onto more
or at least give us like a satisfying
conclusion to the the overarching
stargate story
you know
yeah that thing i was talking about was
the um the canada the
the the canadian dollar got too strong
it was towards the end of atlantis i
don't think it was the main reason why
atlantis um got cancelled but i think it
was a factor
that the american dollar the whole
reason why they set up um in british
columbia in the first place was it was
cheap to make they got a load of tax
breaks and things
and so it was reasonably cheap to make
they it allowed them to push the budget
a lot further and then by the end of um
towards the end of atlantis the the
canadian dollar was so strong all of a
sudden it was actually becoming quite
expensive to make the show
so one thing but um i don't know if that
affected stargate universe in the same
way but stargate universe was a
horrendously expensive show to make
i mean the uh the acting talent on there
was not cheap which is something they'd
never done target that's before you know
it's target it was always relatively
unknown except for richard dean anderson
um
and then
you know it's like
they move on to
in stargate universe you know they did
have proper hollywood a couple of proper
hollywood actors quite quite expensive
contracts in there but it was a
beautifully made show
for me
it was just a bit boring um it was too
slow and i i felt they were they were
hoping to win awards i think they were
looking at what battlestar galactica was
doing
and how how they'll get such critical
acclaim and they thought oh let's do
that
and let's make something that's good
that's really and don't get me wrong
it's it's it's by far the most
beautifully made of all the stargate
series
and it was just a bit boring and
particularly the first series the second
series did pick up it was getting better
but i think sci-fi shows should always
have at least two seasons
if tng had just gone on that star trek
next generation if we just got on the
first series and that would have been
cancelled it would have been the death
of the franchise because the first
series wasn't very good
um it got better towards the end of the
first series but it was only really
a third the way through the second
series of that show got any good
yeah and when they basically sent the
forge off down to engineering with no
training and tasha yard died and they
realized that actually klingon would be
a very good security chief
and you know that when they sort of
reorganized that
you know it was brilliant so i mean um
so the football i i just feel
like my actual thoughts on universe was
it was very ambitious
um and i think
i don't know i don't think
the fan base was ready for that
kind of tv show because i think
i do think it was slightly ahead of its
time
yeah but it would work really well now
if it came out but it didn't then
it was yeah maybe it was a start but i
always felt i just thought it was forced
they were trying to agree something but
i felt that both atlantis and the
universe ended prematurely i think the
stories had a lot more in them atlantis
most definitely ended prematurely
um you know i've done a couple of videos
recently about atlanta um
we've got one on stargate atlantis
coming out soon
basically saying about
brad wright has talked about with both
wanting to bring a conclusion to it
i think with stargate universe that
basically means saving them and bringing
them home
but stargate atlantis
is it just having atlantis in or does it
mean we have to actually defeat the
wraith i don't know
but either way it's good we need a
satisfying conclusion for the rafe for
sure yeah well that means bringing in a
new bad for potential sixth season or
you know just ending it there
yeah i'm happy with both let's not
preempt that video that i haven't put up
yet
really
um
but look okay so brad right
obviously he
he presided over you could argue the end
of stargate because i mean you say what
we like about stargate universe not
enough people watched it people vote
with their feet and they didn't watch it
it was too expensive and they didn't get
the viewing figures so it got cancelled
it's there's no other there's that is
the argument that is what happened
i think a lot of that came about from
the um the slots they were given though
wasn't it
they they had a decent slot to begin
with and then
was it sci-fi they were with
moved it to some like ungodly hour when
no one watched it
but even that though it's if the show if
they loved the show they'd put it on a
decent hour they they put it in the slot
that they think is going to be
um most valuable to them and if they
didn't have confidence in the show they
weren't going to put it in a prime slot
so i mean that's a chicken in the egg
thing but the end of the day nobody
watched the damn show so
we can't really go any more than that um
but for me i mean it was over here in
the uk and it was on sky the same as all
the other um stargate shows had been and
again the viewing figures weren't good
enough
so
excuse me
um but brad wright presided over that so
how much is he to blame
hmm
there is an argument to be made that he
killed stargate
but
i don't know
i'm playing devil's advocate a bit there
because i don't think
so if you say when you say no one
watched it i'm there screaming i watched
it i watched it
and i loved it
well of course if you're the only one i
know i think it's one of those marmite
shows and any americans watching will
not understand that reference at all but
it's one of those marmite shows that
people loved it or hated it but some
people oh i don't know unfortunately the
sad thing was too many people just
completely irrelevant to it they just
didn't care
um but
for me
i just always felt like it was boring so
i wasn't i didn't i watched it
still better than anything else on the
channel it's still stargate at the end
of the day like i say um so i still
enjoyed the show but i just wish it was
more interesting did you know what the
only problem with it was they sucked the
humor out of it
that was that was the problem they
sucked the humor out of it it was not it
was it was more gritty
more uh yeah more serious
yeah
i kind of like that though i i liked
that it was different that's i don't
know
i i just like that difference
that's the thing with any sci-fi any tv
show or reboot or revamp of anything
um they're stuck there's a catch-22
isn't it that if you do
if you follow the same formula
you'll get moaned that but no they're
just doing the same thing again you know
if they'd have another wise cracking
commander and you know like like they
kind of did with atlantis really it's
you know with shepard he was you know a
bit he was a bit he wasn't quite but a
bit like richard dean anderson
over his role um if they did that again
you're gonna you know you'll just go on
here they go again it's just following
the same formula um but then if they
change it too much you've got the same
people probably go in well this isn't
stargate
why is cracking commander
sort of thing you know it's like did you
follow the formula or do you get bone in
the so to change it or do you not you
know
the video you made recently um
i don't know if it was a live show or if
you made it an actual video i can't
remember but you basically oh no it was
your video why star trek is better than
uh target is better than star trek you
hit the nail on the head that stargate
needs to be funny
yeah um
because that's what makes that's
having that
uh comic relief in amongst some of the
most more serious episodes
just makes or breaks the show i think
yeah
like sg1 had some really serious
episodes like heroes um but also had
some really fun episodes like with wind
of opportunity
yeah
one of the funniest episodes in history
but i i made the argument in that video
isn't it that actually in real life
particularly in very stressful
situations people do
have a sense of humor i i've worked with
the nhs the health service here i've
worked in mental health or which in
other areas where they're very serious
very stressful and for me the more
stressful the job
and this the stupider the sense of humor
is because you need to vent so when
people say oh this is a gritty drama
it's so realistic and i'm like well if
it was realistic they would be taking
the piss out of each other they would
there would be some humor there because
that's how people cope
um
and and that's the issue but i did i
don't think they i don't see why they
went from though
a character it was
obviously o'neill was suicidal
and then he he felt better and then he
became quite a wisecracker but then in
sg universe they just had a suicidal
commander and he just stayed like a
drunk suicidal like depressive all the
way through and i know he came to
redemption towards the end but
i just i just found the characters
boring but
um
but like i said still stargate
it's still better than everything else
on telly yeah um it's just not it's just
my least favorite but for me i i
wouldn't mind
um
if at like if stargate if there are
people amazon
and then today they on the show they'll
do what they like but if they could
bring in some fresh blood and they could
bring in somebody new as long as they
brought in the right person and they
didn't do a star trek let's change let's
turn the klingons into some sort of
weird thing let's let's let's have a you
know a hard reboot and let's bring
um
uh sorry just i just yeah uh you saw my
um rda there richard anderson made
stargate he was a genius but there was a
comment earlier somebody's heard that
he's coming back i think that was just
for the um
the live show wasn't it the um that's
the aire doesn't it
yeah well
i got accused just to change subject
completely now i got accused of being
them click beta
a couple of days ago really annoyed me
because i work really hard not to try to
click great people
um but i tried to do titles that are
serious you know and he went on and on
and on about me about clickbait
somebody's a vaper
um but anyway
so
um
i but i there is a show i do i do watch
their videos occasionally i'm gonna have
to i'll give i'll give them a shout out
let me google in a sec
and they do clickbait they're terrible
um for it
um
podcast
um
and they they're they're the one of
these people that do 15 minute videos
but they only actually tell you like one
or two minutes worth of information and
they spend most of the video telling you
to just wait until the end of the video
we're going to tell you something really
insane but in the meantime don't forget
to subscribe and like and they go on and
on and on you know it's one of those
sort of places but they did a video
recently and their video was could
richard dean anderson return stargate
all right
um but then all they actually talk about
is that thing on companion with um brad
right and the virtual thing
there was rumors that they would about
six months ago that they would like
richard you manson to come back to
stargate
but if they did it would literally be
as samantha carter's husband
and he would make he would have a very
small role and it would maybe one or two
sort of like visits and that would be a
way of getting fans on board
particularly if there were quite large
changes to
some of the plots or some of the scripts
to to like just placate fans and calm
them all
announced
i sat through 15 minutes to get to
something i already knew
um it was annoying
um
thomas leader joe you are awesome i am i
keep telling people that i'm awesome and
they don't believe me
but um
and andrew again don't worry i'll send
him a box of tissues
thank you
um but yeah so now this idiot was at the
right moment at me but what people are
gonna do i'm just i'm just quickly
reading through it now
it's on i've got this video loaded open
because there was a comment i left and i
wanted to read it
based on the whole brad right discussion
um and yeah i've just seen it
go for a quick look
yeah well
when you're ready
well
finish what you're talking about first
so
if you are new to the channel like
subscribe hit that bell notification if
you want to go to sidetrack.com you can
buy amazing glasses like that
and please consider joining the channel
and becoming
a fully fled sidetracker you can hit the
join button and we've got all that
nonsense anyway so
um
he would be retired
so once he's retired he could marry her
so yes he could he could marry her in
this new series because he would be
retired and that's all what we want to
see in it we want to see jack and sam
together um
that would be amazing and i'd love to
see that i'd love to see the opening of
the new series to be there i'm getting
married that would be the opening sir
everybody could you imagine that all
this fans would go
insane if that was the opening to the um
to the new series
um i'm just giving brad writer an idea
there i might send it to him
um
so yeah what were we talking about
somebody get in the comments that's what
we were talking about
you were just talking about the
the comment but before that we're
talking about brad wright uh potentially
not being the showrunner
when you made that video yesterday i i
commented this and this this was my
thoughts um if they if they did get rid
of brad i would still watch it because
i'm desperate to watch more star more
stargate
but i do think
um amazon would be shooting themselves
in the foot
um
i'll just read it now brad has been a
massive part of stargate since its
inception and although i agree fresh
blood would be good
it worked for doctor who no revival it
comes with so many risks and i don't
know if amazon can pull off a russell t
davis rivalesque move
yeah especially when brad himself is
fighting so hard uh for his vision
because he's got the fans behind him if
they bought in new fans uh new blood
essentially with him still trying to you
know make his vision come true i think
it would uh muddy the waters a bit
i think 100 i do wonder if that's why
brad wright is
going on companion going on twitter and
going all these other things and talking
about as much as and just making sure he
reminds fans don't forget i'm stargate
basically stargate's my baby thing
because
i think he knows amazon for considering
his position
so if he gets out there and he keeps
talking about it he does these
companions he gets rich dean anderson on
there he gets amanda tapping
it makes it very very difficult for brad
wright to not be involved at all but it
does mean amazon could um
sidestep him in some ways or bring
somebody else in do other things to
other executive producers maybe there
are ways they could
you know um
not make him all powerful basically do
you know to me not make him the boss he
might be the top man but with
they could bring him in for
they could like greenlight a first
season have him be the showrunner for
the first season and then phase him out
like that could that could literally be
what they end up doing
yeah it might be and i think at the end
of the day brad wright would pretty much
accept anything whatever amazon said if
they said we're going to make stargate
book this this and this i think you'd
agree because he loves the show
um you know it's it's it's you can tell
how much he loves the show and he talks
and joseph malozy as well i think
jeffrey melissa gets half a chance to
come back he would because he adores it
you know
um and but i think
just because they love it though doesn't
necessarily mean they're the right
people they need to have the right
vision and
if they don't have the right vision i
would say it's very brave for amazon but
if they think no we need to go somewhere
new i say
go it and and the show will either die
or or succeed and it'll be amazon's
fault
um
but i think that the issue at the moment
somebody's somebody asked me saying
about um and it was mentioned earlier
about um roland demeric
that um now it's been sort of brought
into amazon umbrella it looks like
amazon studios will make the new series
of stargate and somebody said well what
does that mean for brad then is it you
know is he still contracted to it what
does that mean the contracts are going
to be exactly the same because it is mgm
that own the rights amazon can move that
and make it at
um amazon studios but it'll still say
mgm productions
in association and the contracts they
have with mgm they're still going to say
the same
that that's why amazon haven't just like
suddenly put all of mgm's films and
everything onto amazon prime because
they can't
because mgm has contracts with other
tv providers and things and those
contracts are still legally binding just
the fact that amazon have come in and
bought it doesn't make any difference
they've got to wait for those contracts
to expire
and that goes in with roland emmerich in
the same point that when he was talking
about this a little while ago um he
would he actually made the point that if
amazon decided to make a movie
if they want him to be involved he kind
of has to be because he's contracted to
so there is a contract somewhere to say
if they create stargate movie
roland emmerich
has to be involved and if they want him
to
um he could just say no and they could
say no but there is a contract involved
i think the lord of the rings will
showcase what kind of stargate we could
possibly end up with
i'm going to do a video on the lord of
the rings
i know people are very very upset about
lord of the rings and i still can't
quite get my head around why
it's they've not even finished making it
yet i'm not saying anything about lord
lurings oh people are furious i've never
seen any behind the scenes or anything
like it's all i'm just waiting until it
comes out
it's all politics but yeah wait for it
to come out um but yeah and lord of the
rings there's already a lot of
negativity but i think people are just
annoyed they're making it at all
um as much as anything else um
well it's supposedly uh it's set before
the events of the movies isn't it yeah
like six thousand years before or
something yeah it's a proper prequel
something i'd love stargate to do
um oh that was something i missed off
the list actually that apparently there
was a few months ago there was
discussions about if the first series of
stargate works and it would be 10
episodes
you know i said about how they want to
do this marvel esque style and i've
talked about a few times in videos that
they would want two or three series that
all intertwined with each other you know
a bit like and star wars at the moment
with them the book of boba fett how it
intertwined mandalorian and it was
really just like
the third chapter of mandalorian really
um they would want something like that
all the stories sort of like they um um
i was going to say interfere with each
other then but that makes it sound like
they're like
touching each other up or something
um but they all um they will reflect on
each other they will all you know
what happened to one will affect the
other and then the movies would be the
same that they would they would
potentially affect each other
um
if they were to do that with amazon one
of the things they could do and i would
adore and they apparently there have
been discussions is a prequel series
and i hate prequels i hate prequels i
hate them so much
um it i just think with a prequel series
um set in the second age i don't really
know what that means but um well
afterwards the reason
an ancients prequel could work with
stargate is because they're an advanced
race to us it's futuristic
so even though it's set in the past it's
still futuristic enough for it to be
like amazing and like we're not it's not
like sword fighting and horses and you
know what we see like
on like every other tv show when they go
into the past it's futuristic and it's
exciting and it's things that we haven't
seen
um and stories that
will eventually um
i don't know
in interference i'm going to usually
interfere with sg1 and atlantis later on
i'm interfering with you
well yeah
for once we can have a prequel series
that doesn't tiddle all over canon
um i'm trying to be good enough swear
aren't i good um it doesn't tiddle all
over canon
um and actually could add to canon
instead because how many times in
stargate do we've seen little things
about the the ancients even the building
the gates we had little teasers you know
that bloke with his um as he's trying to
escape them out with the uh the the
other designs for the gate on like a
piece of paper and things with little
teasers
even stuck at universe we could we could
find out so much more about that we saw
we saw the ship the gates being built on
the sea chips
i'd like
because one of the biggest questions
from
atlantis probably more primarily but
even sg1 is how on earth is zpm created
as epm created
i'd love to see that i would love even
if it's just a throwaway scene just just
just to see that you know that that
would sort of make me think about like
certain stargate episodes and things
there's a star trek episode sorry i'd
love to see lynn like building a zpm but
then the the whole little mini series
would be
one while their designs there's an
accident and there's you know that could
be a really interesting like double
episode when then they're fighting to
sort of like but in the end they figure
out how to build this because that would
be a match i imagine an incredibly
dangerous piece of a technology to get
wrong
so that is such an interesting episode
we guess we could learn something about
zpm's which is such an integral part
particularly to target atlantis
um but then as well have an element of
danger and threat and you know whatever
that would be such an interesting double
episode
like this i'd like to imagine they'd
have the same sort of trouble that mckay
had with his
with his bridge
um where he was extracting zero-point
energy from an alternate universe rather
than a artificial universe which is epm
is yes so they probably tried that
something messed
up yeah
or even that they're using maybe that is
drawn energy for someone else but you
know they again
do like a trekkie type thing you know
when they're in the star trek episodes
when they realize that
the warp drive was damaging space
that was causing so they could really
you know they have these epms in there
actually they realize that it's actually
causing harm to somebody else
um
sorry everyone's talking about
lord of the rings we'll do a lord of the
rings video i promise guys at some point
oh i've set siri off now
should've siri
um
but yeah there are so many possibilities
even like building the star game you
know there's so many possibilities in
there that they could have for going
wrong um
but then i i just i'd love
i just think that there are so many ways
i mean
the game is time keepers and they they
are actually jumping through time in the
game apparently
i was told a little while ago look out
for that because that's one of the
things amazon
have talked about saying that they would
love the
game
to sort of reflect where they were going
to go over the next few years
and he said time travel is
a big um possibility for where the
series could go and how they could
intertwine all these things together
because the gates give them that
possibility
and he also he also said i am and all he
said was mirror universe this smiley
face that's all you'd ever say
and you never said anything else and i'm
gonna have a lot more stories for sure
wouldn't it because you'd
traveling in time you could just go back
and you'd have to go order the bad guys
again you could have
the replicators and even further back
the actual faith in their prime
and i mean you could always do things
like um
like marvel did where you know they go
back in time and things get messed up
and it changes things but i would hate
that if they did a star trek
um you know a jj abrams star trek thing
where they went actually we can change
everything because it's okay we change
time and this is an alternate universe
now that would piss me off i don't want
him to do that um
i did promise i wouldn't swear i'm so
sorry um
but it's you know um somebody's there
put stargate multiverse yeah exactly we
don't i don't want that though do we to
be honest i think it's it's lazy
um
i like the multiverse stories when
there's parallel versions of the team
and stuff coming in but i don't think we
should have
as you say rewrites and
this event has has changed everything
that happened before
because that is essentially just a hard
reboot isn't it it's it's off
and it's just it's just lazy writing as
well but um all of them will be soft
reboots anything they do will be soft
reboots unless they bring all the
original actors back which won't be a
hard reboot if um
yeah if they basically change everything
um but or they pretend like the first
series never happened but i've been told
repeatedly that won't happen that that
amazon know if they tried to do a hard
reboot there'd be a revolt
there's this people definitely pretty
much
um they got away with star trek and then
but i think they've learned their lesson
from star trek though as well because
everything you know like like early
discovery episodes where the klingons
were different
we're not going to see that in the card
series 3 because they're just going to
pretend like that didn't happen
and all the creepy klingons that we saw
in discovery series one and discovery
series one yeah um we're not going to
see that in guard series three so i'm
hoping stargate learns from
their mistakes star trek's mistakes and
don't do it
but that's one thing i think is really
interesting with canon and stargate i
can't think of a single time because i'm
doing another part of that video um
star trek stargate is better than the
star trek and my next thing is going to
be canon star trek peas all over canon
every chance it gets it's it's almost
like they do it on purpose
um it's almost like they change little
things just to see if anyone notices and
we're trekkies we notice
um i just wonder if they i can't think
of a single time star gate did that
i was trawling through all the episodes
trying to think is when has stargate
ever
made a major cannon error
and i don't think they ever did
i can't think of any and it's like three
hundred and something episodes you know
so they've got there's plenty of
episodes there to you know nearly 400
episodes i think including this to you
there's there's plenty of opportunities
to screw
um
through canada but they never did
i'm sure they made mistakes they made
mistakes with science and things like
this i'm certain there are um but they
never really
there's definitely some some
um
in universe
like rules that they've broken
like with the zac nicotel
david they're probably
that changed over time they didn't they
realized that was a kind of stupid
weapon
and um there was they i think it was
like a few episodes before or maybe a
season before i can't remember when it
was
um they introduced what it was you got
the
one shot stuns two shots kills three
disintegrates but it has to be open for
it to do any of this stuff and then
there was the episode where ryak was
basically
brainwashed by apophis so
uh what's his name tilke
um shoots him but doesn't actually open
the weapon
yeah i think that still works that's
just the thing the error there isn't i
think it's not just a designer like a
you know a continuity or rather than i
was just like how long do you have to
because they say they shoot you wants
to stun shoot you twice to kill shoot
you three times to disintegrate they
seem to forget about the disintegrated
one as well after the first couple of
episodes um but how long does the energy
stay in you
so can you get stunned and then as long
as you leave a few hours you can get
stunned again
or you know well they didn't they
didn't they shoot
um o'neill a few times
during the episode with
uh cadet
hayley
oh yeah i love her she's because because
of the bugs
um
they didn't like the electricity
yeah um i said the only bit of three
memphis when they had multiple actors
playing multiple characters everything
star trek was the worst for that
star trek would have one act to play
eight nine different characters quite
regularly
stargate did it with people like the guy
that played i can't say his name because
it's impossibly like northern names to
say but um
um
the guy that played top he played
several different characters didn't he
he was also in
uh he was in a few he's got an amazing
voice
uh that's eager that's elon who's buying
the show oh if if elon musk bought the
show how could that be it's never gonna
happen but you know how good you're
laughing
he he'd if he loved most sports target
he would build the ships like they would
actually be real working ships they
could build a stargate
it would become a documentary
rather than a science fiction tv
hmm um what do you think i was going to
ask about um so yeah so if if brad
wright
weren't to be in the show like we said i
don't think of the in the world as long
as they brought somebody good in but i
think i
my personal opinion though is that the
amazon aren't stupid enough to do that
if they they might bring him in with a
bunch of provisos and a bunch of like uh
if but some babies and or you know am i
putting training wheels on him something
but i don't think they would sack him
but i think i know they've talked about
it you remember i did a video a few
months ago and i said that um
brad wright was in the building at um
um beverly hills and i had to apologize
to say no he wasn't
um i've since been told
that actually um this was completely
separate i was only told this about two
weeks ago that there were a bunch of
meetings about brad wright
um at um executive things just before
these big summits and i never put two
and two together initially
but now i've suddenly realized i wonder
if that's what the bloke saw
he saw the brad's name his name and it
was a bowser
he wasn't actually attending but he
wasn't actually intended so it was um so
i do wonder i've never i haven't
actually asked the bloke that told me
because um he stopped talking to me
after that
after i did the video and i apologized
um he virtual hug thank you thank you
jack
um
he i basically he he thought that i was
calling him a liar and because he said i
am a hundred percent convinced
i saw his name on these meetings and
then i come obviously that video saying
i'm sorry brad wright has told me
himself he wasn't there and i do think
this guy genuinely made a genuine
mistake he basically saw branson
wright's name on these meetings
saw a bloke that he thought was brad
wearing a bloody mask across the room
and then just put two two together and
made six
so i think it was a genuine mistake but
now this other guy's told me another we
were a bunch of means about but it was
simply they weren't like anything
nefarious it was simply
the mgm executives and people know brad
the amazon people coming in don't know
him stargate is considered to be a big
role so they had some means to say well
you know what what's he like what are
his priorities what does he want to do
and that's all these meetings were
apparently but
um
that that's what happened
i'm hoping so because but like i said
he's never he's never spoken to me since
he says he thinks i thought called him a
liar and i wasn't i was trying to be
really honest but the end of the day if
brad wright
tells you off
and says i wasn't there
you know you don't have a choice you've
got to issue an apology
honestly brother is enthusiasm for the
show isn't just
i think it is i think he's right i watch
him on the content you know continuum
and stuff and
he freaking loves the show
you can't you know you can't own about
it you know um and it is somebody else
kevin said it's his baby and i and i
think it's right you know he he
absolutely adores the show but so does
people like michael shanks and and
amanda tapping i think these are the
people that will be brought in behind
the camera
i can remember it's not these people
wrote show wrote episodes teal
you know um christopher judge could come
back and write episodes he wrote some
brilliant episodes and um i think he'll
be right back too but um
it would be interesting to see if these
these breedies can bring these people in
really it'll be amazing
so where we are at the moment then
does it concern you at all
amazon studios sort of absorbing these
things and they say well we're going to
make it rather than mgm studios does
that but they didn't bother you in the
slightest
not really
because
you've said it before
amaz mgm would use other studios anyway
so even if it was
mgm doing it they'd be using other
studios so it
sounds
very much the same
i don't think it makes any difference
um
the only thing and amazon have made some
good good shows over the last few years
you know i love that i'm lucifer tv show
you know like it was on netflix amazon
bought it continued making it through
the production company it was making it
they just let them make the show
um i think if they brought brad right in
um
he would just be a pretty much allowed
to make sure he wants to make they'll
just fund it but
they will i think there will be some
they will put some protections in
um
you know jack doesn't bother me either i
don't i don't think it's an issue i just
think it's word because i was in such a
big company they're not necessarily they
haven't got the history of mgm but what
i'm being told is amazon are going to be
cherry-picking talent from mgm
they're going to be taking entire
um you know sections out of mgm and
absorb them into amazon
um and
you know so it might actually end up
being the same people anyway
um it's just
it'll have
amazon's name on it as well as mgm's
that's all it really i don't think it'll
make a difference
the only worry i have with amazon
is they do listen to fans but i think
sometimes they listen a bit too much
um
the only example i can give on this is i
don't know if you've heard of the gate
the game new world
yes um
it's been in development for years
proper
like massive hype for it was meant to be
a full loop pvp game
um
and yeah
at some point during the they did like
an open beta or something like that and
at some point during that open beta
um
everyone was basically like we don't
like full loot pvp
so that's
basically within two years
redone the entire game
and then they released it in a in such
an unfinished state
that the game is now dead
it's not dead it still has like 30 000
people playing it but they had a million
people playing it on day one and now i
only have 30 000.
right okay it's slightly it's i know
game development is slightly different
than tv shows but
yeah i don't know i i i don't know if
they if they listen to the wrong people
are they going to make changes that
have done but i think you've got a good
point now because we know they do a lot
of surveys and things because that was
one thing we got excited about a couple
of months ago they were putting surveys
out to people talking about the expanse
and do you like the expense would you
like to see more the experience but also
stargate do you like stargate do you
like do you would you like new stargate
or do you watch the old stargate what
would you like if you did and they put
these surveys out now i don't mind them
collecting data
but are they taking a scientific
approach where actually
it requires a bit of
art rather than just
the science you know
yeah because just like just having a
hundred thousand people say yes we want
stargate or
thousands of people saying no we don't
right
is that my accent tunes that's making
you fun i'm making you giggle
uh i i have lots of little twangs i am
i'm one of those first of my generation
in england so they watched far too much
american tv when i was a kid so um i i
have these little american twangs
occasionally that click it's my my
accent is so confused it's it's all over
the place
um but yeah
so now i i i worry about that with
amazon sometimes as well that instead of
like creating a show
that they're passionate about they try
to create shows that are formulaic
that fit
hit the demographics they want to hit
sort of thing
rather than doing something that's brave
and exciting which means sometimes it'll
fail but sometimes it'll
succeed
um
but then they do things like um reacher
which is a fantastic series
um you know
and the boys which is i mean that is
that is a brave show i mean that is
horrendous in places you know
um it's gruesome it's so gruesome but
it's
probably one of my favorite things
they've ever done
yeah it's my favorite thing they've ever
done
i i i think so as well i think it's a
fantastic show and um and it's you know
um
oh some of the things that get into a
nice series it's like
the the main guy i can't remember his
name oh he's like superman what's his
name what's going on
homelander homelander and he's um he's
doing that chick against the nazi
against the wall and this is he's doing
he's holding some guy against the wall
he crushes his head because he's heading
to the wall yeah
he's holding his girlfriend's hands and
the and you know the flash guy comes
through um you know express train what's
his name servicing train comes through
and i can see explodes just like what
the bloody hell is that i can't wait for
the third series it's amazing
the ending of the was it the second
episode that's what clinched it for me
being a fantastic show where he blew up
the guy
yeah the invisible fell
yeah that was blue
um i didn't think the second series was
as good as the first series but um but
yeah it's it's good and i had really
dark moments as well you know when the
um the main girl she joins the seven and
she has to give fish boy her job
basically and they're seriously dark
moments in that series as well
um
and then i don't know that's a great
show i'm so that does show that amazon
can be brave and can do something that
but or you could argue actually they
watched um
deadpool and when
let's do something along those lines
what's out there so you could argue that
actually they weren't that brave but now
that show is i tried to watch it my wife
i said look watch this boat it's so
funny
and the um the first time
i think he says see you next tuesday my
wife is just like nope
nope done
um there's a word we cannot say on here
or we would be what's his name butcher
what's his real i can't think of his
name oh he's been he's been um he was in
star trek weren't he yeah oh yeah he's
bones oh god i do know his name he's
going to annoy me he was in a tv series
with them about robots and stuff and
only lasted half a series and it was
fantastic
um
oh it's gonna annoy me
carl urban
carl urban yeah he's one of those great
actors he was in
as well he played a really good part as
a necromancer in um
the chronicles of riddick which is one
that i think i genuinely think is one of
the most underrated
um
they get a young actor good actor to
play the doctor talk about doctor who
now in the uh
yeah actually looks like he's going to
be pretty pretty good i'm quite excited
for him yeah he's i think he's quite
i've didn't know he was because i never
watched sex education but i i googled i
watched a couple of clips and he just
looked like quite an interesting
character yeah a wide range and really
an actor with a lot of range i think he
could be good
um but yeah carl urban um i thought the
um his take on
um dread
was was good i think the film wasn't
great but i thought his he was good was
dread
um
and one of the things i liked about that
as well that he what didn't take his
helmet off a great deal which and other
actors would have gone i've got to take
my helmet off people gotta see my face
screen time yeah but he didn't he didn't
build it into his contract he went dread
doesn't take his helmet off i've got to
play it like this i think that's one of
the reasons why robot cop crap because
the actor they had to excel my pepsi's
face i must like don't it's not i think
almost human that was the series
if ever you get a chance watch calling
me an almost human
it's a fantastic series and it got cut
off halfway through the first um thing
so i think we only got about 10 episodes
but it's really really good
um
stallone
they were a bit silly with stallone um
stallone's dread but yeah it's a good
film on the whole
but yeah but yeah dredge was great
but that's an interesting shot anyway
we're hitting an hour
so um
i just i just wanted to do another thing
go after with a recap see what people
for
um i'm going live on my other youtube
channel in
30 minutes
um
on the machine so if you want to go
across and subscribe to that if you
haven't already that would be amazing
and please go and find matt's um channel
as well
um you know because you know he's
working hard on there and uh if you go
on the facebook group the psytric
facebook group you put your videos in
there didn't you make so
i yeah some of them in there
mostly they go on discord um
just just get some there
uh
oh i need a discord link actually
so yeah go and also join our discord
link it's a great way to go and chat and
moan about everything
um so you know we really want you to do
that as well um you know talk to each
other come up with some good ideas for
things
let me know
thank you very much sir that's the
discord link up
um if you see any other soon as it comes
up on my side i will
link it i will post it to the top
um if you
have any ideas for videos you want us to
talk about or things you want us to talk
about and i think matt is going to come
back in a week or two and we're going to
do a look at series 2
of stargate because that's personally
one of my favorites
um
uh they could have passed around podcast
and stargate
cool i think it would be cool if they
wrote parts for the people who ran
podcasts okay yeah cool that'd be me
i wanna i wanna
i think i might share a link for your
channel if you can while you're on there
i've put it in the chat a couple of
times
cool okay so it's theirs for somebody
um shelly has just shared the
link for the facebook group so please go
and join that too if you haven't already
i'm always putting stuff up there and
you can ask me anything on there so i'm
jamie on there you'll see my name's all
over it um anything you want
but i'd love ideas for videos you wanted
to talk about in the future that's what
i was sorry going on um anything you
want to talk about we're going to come
back we're going to do like a review of
series 2 because i honestly think series
2 or stargate sg1 was when it really
took off and when it became stargate
that we love and i think it's one of the
strongest series of any of them so i
think it'd be really interesting we'll
have a chat about that
um but anything else you want us to talk
about please come on
um
and yeah 556t
halo has a tv series um if i don't know
if you're in the uk or america but it
should be on paramount plus went live
today i believe in the uk i haven't had
time to look at it yet but it should be
on it
um so hopefully we're going to be i'm
going to actually be able to watch it
um
but that would be amazing so
thanks everybody for joining thanks matt
for taking an hour out of your sunday
afternoon to come and chat stargate
um and for everything you can discord
channel and everything else and
um that's really is helpful and it's you
know it's really brilliant so please go
join that
if you're new to the channel like
subscribe hit the bell notification do
all that you can share the video or over
the hell you like um
yep please make sure you've subscribed
to both channels and we will see you
very very soon
say bye-bye
bye
bye guys thanks so much have a be safe
see you soon bye
[Music]
you